I am a 28 year old white South African
male that's all you need to know about
me to form an immediate opinion but what
if I am you and you are me what if we
are everybody connected not through
blood but bound by survival this idea is
what brought together 100 filmmakers
from 100 different countries around the
globe 100 opinions one goal hey who are
you
I can a casual way who are you actually
let's start right at the beginning
you're definitely human unless you're
watching this really far into the future
and in that case hello new species if
you have access to this video you have
routine
it may not be structured but you eat
when you're hungry and you sleep when
you're tired you have a dream the need
to feel somewhat significant which you
are but you need to know it adventure
and uncertainty keep you wondering keep
you curious to learn but most
importantly you need connection
connection to people now more than ever
the points of the imagery on the screen
is to showcase that and see hidden in
plain sight a lens with no boundaries no
script just a hundred foemen kids with a
dream across 100 different cultures from
east to west imagery untouched
and processed
look at all these people
look at this man smiling at his son that
feeling you vault right there that's
called connection in a world of
organized chaos chaos organized to keep
you from imagining a world that hasn't
been advertised characterized not by
your disguise but loved for what's
inside ever wondered how dancing to
music is speaking every language at once
imagine a world with no language only
feeling who then would be the most
gifted world needs to reimagine not the
Shakespearean understanding love is
blind but rather imagine the world as
one like Lennon's mind
who are you this should not be defined
by an act
[Music]
if you couldn't start with your
qualification status would job what
would you answer to that
[Music]
you are a divine being you are loved
[Music]
you are made up of one lifetime while on
earth atleast
just as day moves in tonight you're
growing older
make change before it's too late
the smallest gestures are we change
begins therefore make them great
[Applause]
now ask yourself Who am I really
and what are you gonna do with that to
make change thing is you've just started
[Applause]
[Music]
you